F
THE ATTACKS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS THAT TEXAS
ABORTION LAW IS AN UNAMERICAN
VIGILANTE SYSTEM.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS REFUSED TO
STOP THE NEW REGULATIONS.
AND THAT'S INTENSIFYING
DEMOCRATIC EFFORTS TO CHANGE THE
MAKEUP OF THE HIGH COURT AND GET
RID OF THE SENATE FILIBUSTER.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY HAS THE LATEST ON THAT
TONIGHT.
>> I HAVE BEEN CONTINUE TO BE A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF ROE V. WADE.
>> AND BEFORE ROE V. WADE IS
CHALLENGED IN FRONT OF THE
SUPREME COURT, PRESIDENT BIDEN
IS WORRIED BECAUSE THEY, JUST
UPHELD A TEXAS LAW RESTRICTING
ABORTION.
>> THE MOST PERNICIOUS THING
ABOUT THE TEXAS LAW IS SORT OF
CREATES A VIGILANTE SYSTEM WHERE
PEOPLE GET REWARDS TO GO OUT --
ANYWAY.
AND IT JUST SEEMS -- I KNOW THIS
SOUNDS RIDICULOUS, ALMOST
UNAMERICAN.
>> PROGRESSIVES HAVE HAD IT.
AOC TWEETS:  REPUBLICANS PROMISE
TO OVERTURN ROE V. WADE AND THEY
HAVE.
DEMOCRATS CAN EITHER ABOLISH THE
FILIBUSTER AND EXPAND THE COURT
OR DO NOTHING.
SOME PROGRESSIVES HAVE ALREADY
OUTLINED HOW THEY WOULD DO IT.
>> WE UNDO THE DAMAGE,
REPUBLICANS HAVE DONE BY
RESTORING BALANCE AND WE DO IT
BY PASSING THE JUDICIARY ACT OF
2021 TO ADD FOUR SEATS TO THE
COURT TO CREATE A 13-MEMBER
SUPREME COURT.
>> PRESIDENT DESCRIBES HIMSELF
AS A.
>> STUDENT OF HISTORY.
>> AND HISTORICALLY BEEN AGAINST
EXPANDING THE COURT LIKE WHEN
FDR TRIED.
>> HE VIOLATED NO LAW.
HE WAS LEGALISTICALLY ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT.
BUT IT WAS A BONE HEADED IDEA.
>> BUT AS PRESIDENT, HE HAS
ORDERED A COMMISSION OF EXPERTS
TO BRIEF HIM ON THE PROS AND
CONS OF COURT PACKING.
AND IN HIS MIND IS OPEN.
>> THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ON THE STRUCTURE OF
THE COURT.
>> HE'S WAITING FOR THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS REPORT.
LOOKS FORWARD TO REVIEWING IT.
SEEING WHERE THEY COME OUT.
>> Pete: IF THE PRESIDENT
DECIDES HE WANTS TO ADD FOUR
SPOTS TO THE COURT AND FILL THEM
WITH PROGRESSIVES, HE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO DO IT WHILE DEMOCRATS
CONTROL CONGRESS WHICH COULD
MAKE THE FIGHT AHEAD THE
UPCOMING MIDTERMS THE EQUIVALENT
OF A KWAME KAVANAUGH